all of these pictures be sun-dappled
landscapes and surreal undersea worlds
the abstract sculptures and slightly
hazy futures were all made here in the
video game called minecraft it's the
type of art that gets collected in
coffee-table books and gets made by
design collectives with more than 100
million copies sold minecraft has become
more than a game this game has become an
artistic medium and it is also a
business but even though minecraft is a
liberating game building a business in a
virtual world can be just as tricky as
building it in the real one
at first I thought okay you know the
graphics aren't great but I had a sort
of childhood fascination with Lego and
about two weeks after buying the game I
got kind of bored of the whole survival
aspect and then started looking at this
thing called creative mode
James Delaney is from London and he is
one of the people who runs black works
in artistic collective and company he's
talking about how minecraft works
players choose between two different
modes one is survival mode which is a
little like a traditional video game
since scary spiders and other creatures
come out at night
there's also creative mode it is a blank
canvas in which players can design
unique worlds it really is like making
something out of Legos you arrange a
variety of digital blocks with tons of
options to increase the complexity as
minecraft grew a new industry grew with
it to play Minecraft online players
choose from a bunch of different servers
that can host the game in the beginning
these servers weren't owned by Mojang
the company that created minecraft so as
different servers tried to attract
players they added lots of bells and
whistles like intriguing worlds or maps
and even their own mods of the game in
industry was born all sorts of companies
and guilds run up to make minecraft maps
just like players they were located all
around the world we have another
director Sean Davidson who's over in
Canada we have 62 members from over 20
different countries but everything's
done remotely so there's no office with
more than one person in it their company
block works started with maps for
servers but the artistic potential kept
them going though they might beautify
their work using plugins and textures
all of it is made in game with obsessive
detail that fans can download and
appreciate for themselves they create
beautiful surreal worlds like a map
about Minecraft of the game or a
beautiful dreamscape of clouds I started
thinking about this city which should be
constructed from from giant music
instruments with a very sort of
mechanical kind of steampunk theme as
minecraft grew big companies saw
potential to promote their stuff through
minecraft maps' block works scored
tie-ins for movies like Tomorrowland
in Batman V Superman they even made a
Batmobile but as unusual as it sounds
building ads inside virtual worlds is
not a new idea
this is chexquest
a 1996 game built on top of dooms engine
people got it from a cd-rom inside
checks boxes at the time Doom was
considered an ultra violent video game
so they remade it with checks for his
small fee checks licensed the software
and built a world inside a world that
trend of virtual world ads continued in
Second Life a platform launched in the
2000s that's still going today companies
from Reebok - American Apparel built
virtual stores they're earning a lot of
press but as the platform started to
decline in popularity the headlines
disappeared minecraft however might have
the biggest opportunities and risks in
May 2016 minecraft and mo Jane's current
owner Microsoft declared that branded
partnerships like the glorious Batmobile
were no longer allowed Microsoft said it
didn't feel right were fun it also meant
they wanted to retain control of how
money was made off minecraft maps' block
works made out ok
Microsoft hires them to make gorgeous
maps like the seven wonders of the
ancient world they stayed in the club
while other map makers got kicked out of
the branded map game we're lucky enough
to work with Microsoft and obviously
they're exempt from their own guidelines
I think a lot of other teams did
struggle a result of that and it closed
a lot of doors at the same time it's
quite understandable that the Microsoft
want to keep control over how their
platforms being used collectives like
james's might not mind that much in
addition to Microsoft gigs they have
artistic projects in historical
collaborations so
was commissioned by the Museum of London
it ties in with an exhibition they've
got commemorating Great Fire of London
in 1666 but the change in rules shows
the inherent risks of building your
business in another person's world
promotional map crackdowns and even
limits on private servers have kept the
Minecraft industry kind of uncertain
when you're playing another person's
game night could come at any time and
then it's always survival time we put
links to all the maps we used in this
video in the description so there's a
lot to explore and have fun with now I'm
gonna put this goal block on the ground
okay
[Music]